hi my name is Bob naka I'm speaking
about extracting character networks from
narrative text this afternoon
I'm going to be talking about extracting
character networks from narrative text
so why why this project I've always been
interested in networks I'm not only for
their structure but also the information
that you can organize in a network and
also networks are often used to model
flow of all different kinds of things
molecules data water information things
like that so there are a very powerful
data structure there's been some recent
investigations of old problems using
network analysis these are two examples
that are in the Wolfram data repository
one is the Paul Revere social network of
the in colonial Boston that modeled the
membership of various Patriots in
different lodges as they were called the
red nodes are the lodges and the gray
nodes are the individual colonists and
the question was whether or not Paul
Revere was central to the revolutionary
effort and using graft measures they
were able to show that he was very
central in the network he had a very
high centrality and things like that
he's a member of five of the six lodges
that were modeled here there's also
another Patriot that's identified as an
important contributor as well with a
different mathematical technique not not
based on the the graph structure itself
last spring there was a nice publication
about the Irish Viking network and I
worked with the authors to get their
data into the repository and they it was
about the Battle of Clontarf that was
fought in Ireland almost a thousand
years actually a little over a thousand
years ago the early scholarship on the
battle said that it was the Vikings
excuse me the Irish evicting the Vikings
from
and fifty a hundred years ago the
scholarship
switched and this story was that it was
the Vikings were having intercontinental
took the an almost contemporary
description of the battle it was written
one hundred two hundred years after the
battle but they pulled out all the
individual characters involved in the
battle including Brian Boru you may have
heard of him as an Irish hero and all of
the interactions who spoke to whom was
it friendly was at hostile who fought
whom and so on and they built this
network from it and doing network
analysis on it while there was a fair
amount of Irish Irish conflict the
majority the conflict was Irish Viking
by a number of different measures and
this is showing the whole network here
the blue are the Vikings the green or
the Irish if you look at the friendly
interactions you can see that it's
mostly green and green and blue and blue
and if you look at the negative
interactions it's mostly green and blue
that are connected there are some green
and green connected so there was
inter-clan conflict but it was an
exclusively inter-clan conflict so I
thought you know after I did this work
with them you know wouldn't be cool if I
could take a collection of books that
I've read and analyze the character
networks in them and so what I wanted to
do was build a character networks and
see if they changed over time
if one network stood out against the
others and perhaps why and how do the
different roles of the different groups
of the characters the police the
perpetrators the victims and civilians
the bystanders that are involved you
know how do they contribute to the
structure of the network and and things
like that there were two main characters
throughout most of the books Jim Joe he
born
and Jim Chi and you know is their
relationship always the same it was
lieutenant Lee porn and Sergeant Chi you
know was won by rank or was more
important than the other or not you know
what could the network structure reveal
about that and then finally his daughter
Anne Hillerman has written four more
books in the series tony hillerman
himself passed away a few years ago so
he's no longer writing and I've read one
of her bread her first book and it's
definitely different I mean it's still a
murder mystery it's still Jolie porn and
Jim Chi involved it's still set in New
Mexico and Arizona but there's a
difference in her prose and there's a
difference in her dialogue and so you
know is there a way we can quantify that
with textual analysis so these were my
ambitions last May when I first started
on this so I sat down and took the first
book and on a Saturday in a Sunday
afternoon I basically was able to skim
through it again and tabulate all the
characters that had interactions either
they spoke to each other they wrote to
each other in a letter there was a
description of one character some
somebody describing an interaction
between two other characters or
something like that
and I'm that I could easily manually
create a network so we had 70 characters
that I had identified a little bit of
coding here to standardize the names
pull all the characters out of the first
two columns of the table to create the
edges and we have 77 edges in the table
70 characters and we can make the manual
Network the default layout and with a
little bit of extra coding which is in
the initialization section at the end of
the notebook we can make a nice layout
here where I've labeled the victim
actually the the police here are in blue
here's Joe Leaphorn seems fairly central
here's one of the victim the first
victim that got the whole thing started
somebody else was killed along the way
and then the three red nodes are the the
bad guys and everybody else is a
civilian so at this point reality struck
I was capturing extra interactions not
just who spoke to whom or who was
physically at the same place at the same
time as another character and I was
capturing additional information such as
clan membership and stuff like that if I
was a real sociologist yeah I mean that
would be the real meat of what I was
after but it could be a distraction for
what I was trying to do and if I wanted
to do all 20 books I'd need an army of
graduate students to do it the way I was
doing it so we need to get the books in
electronic form so if you're interested
in doing this sort of work there's
something called Project Gutenberg
they've got nearly 60,000 books in
electronic form that are free to
download to read to analyze and things
like that there are some books in the
same genre a couple of stories by Agatha
Christie are in there these are murder
mysteries there's another one they're
called the legends of King Arthur and
his Knights that's been used by people
to do character identification this one
I looked at also it's a little bit easy
to pick the characters out because their
Lord this and Madam that and so you just
look for these titles and honorifics and
it's real easy to pull out who's who in
my case what I had to do was buy the
books from Kindle and put them on my
laptop and fortunately you can find
where the file is that's not always the
case
other vendors kind of hide where the
files are and then there's an app that
you can get from ePub soft eBook
converter which will convert it from the
various different eBook formats into
plain text and that's what I did
so I got three books for starters the
first one is the blessing way which is
the one that I'm going to talk about
today
the other two are waiting in the wings
to be processed I did so there there's a
number of a couple of pieces of prior
art out there using Wolfram language to
analyze text and what I wanted to do
then was identify the spoken text and
then by association the speaker because
they should be nearby in the body of the
text and then identify the interactions
again by proximity of two people are
speaking to each other they should be in
adjoining paragraphs or almost adjoining
paragraphs early workers in this area
used the same chapter two characters
appeared in the same chapter
they drew an edge between them and the
networks and and that's the Donald Knuth
Network for late miserable as example
data in Wolfram language I wanted to
know if we could do better by looking at
sentence or paragraph structure than
just using you know chapter membership
as as a criterion and when we're all
done we sit back and get to actually
realize how easily our own brains do all
of this and how we have to struggle to
do it computationally so this is
definitely a work in progress these are
the two well okay so yeah this website
here analyzed text and it was just
really word frequencies and things like
that and then John mcloon did something
a little more interesting they followed
character frequency over the course of
over the book Lord of the Flies and then
also analyzed the semantics of the text
to see how it changed over time from
being positive
negative okay so what I based my work on
was using text sentences and text
structure text sentences will take text
and break it up into individual
sentences it uses a neural network in
the background to do that text structure
does the same thing except it can give
you parts of speech for example so
taking the first part of alice in
wonderland'
we can take the sentences out with text
sentences takes a bit to load it so here
we are here are the sentences all broken
out and then for each sentence we can
take text structure of that and using it
without any second argument it will give
you the whole sentence at the lowest
level actually shown at the top here are
the parts of speech and then you combine
let's say an adverb and an adjective you
get an adjective or phrase and so on
noun phrases and build yourself all the
way up to a sentence in the end or we
can get the parts of speech directly
just by asking for that and this is what
I did here I wanted to tag the
individual words and then use that
grammatical structure as patterns to
identify quoted text assuming it would
be spoken text and then finding pronouns
and nouns and proper nouns nearby along
with a verb for example bill said to
identify the speaker for that text so
that was my strategy so okay so this is
the workflow and I'm not going to get
through all of this in detail in the
time that we have so I'll probably skip
over some stuff so a number of things
you know was the text well structured
other typographical conventions are they
are they use consistently different
books are rendered in free text in
different ways the books that I used
here use curly quotes for example so it
was very easy to find the beginning in
the end of a quotation other times
you'll find straight quotes and I so
you have to write be more careful in the
patterns that you write to pick out the
beginning and the end of text chapters
and paragraphs how are they separated
and delimited in this case every
paragraph was separated from the next
one by two newline characters so that
was very easy to do are there special
characters if you have foreign text in
your book and you're in your corpus that
you're working and this one did it had
Navajo text but here they did not
italicize it in the printed book that
was italicized but in the eBook version
or in the plain text it was not in
Agatha Christie's book that I looked at
the French that showed up there had it
was italics in the regular text but in
the plain text it had a leading
underscore and a following underscore to
indicate that it was underlined and
therefore italicized and that those
underscores made trouble for text
sentences and text structures so you've
got to do some data cleaning it's always
needed
we also found cases where a space was
missing after a period at the end of the
sentence so two sentences were glued
together and we needed to fix things
like that we needed to come up with an
overall good design for the data so that
we could work with it easily so a good
data structure design is always needed I
was going to I tried to go through and
use part of speech tagging to identify
characters and while proper nouns will
identify characters they also identify
places so that doesn't help so that was
a dead end I thought I could go through
and go through the text and select you
know ah here's a proper noun you know
somebody's name I can pull it out that
turned out to be a rabbit hole it was
just way way way too slow so if what
somebody was going to pursue that method
they would need some tools to make that
a lot easier what I ended up doing was
using the text element patterns and
string patterns to identify quoted text
and then by adjacency the speaker's so
you know that's how I got the speaker
attribution one thing that's still a
problem is prono pronoun resolution he
and she in it trying to find out to whom
they refer that is a serious research
topic a lot of people are working on
that they're using neural nets for it I
haven't gotten that far yet to work on
that to make to get around that problem
and then finally put it put together a
network so just to give you a little bit
of a flavor what we're dealing with we
can import the book 30,000 characters we
can take a look at the beginning of it
with this helper function called find
view and it just shows the beginning of
the text here that the author of the
title a table of contents there's a and
then it begins with the first chapter
here chapters are turned out where
identified this way so I can look for
this pattern greater than sign space
digit characters space less than sign we
also see that the it turns out that all
the chapters the first three words are
capitalized so this is something we're
going to have to clean up also looking
at the end of the book okay so here's
the end of the first chapter and it ends
here's acknowledgment so that we're at
the end but there's a whole bunch of
after matter that needs to be removed
okay
so this pattern here looking for the
chapters is what I just mentioned and
acknowledgement at the end we can split
everything up there was also it turns
out an acknowledgment section in the
front matter so we can actually start
pulling out our chapters beginning with
this snippet of string so we pulled out
the chapter positions and you can split
them and then get the start and end two
positions and then pull all the chapters
out and so we've got eighteen chapters
in the book and the way I've set this up
I pull out the title some books have you
know a brief phrase as the title this
book did not and so depending on the
work you're doing that may or may not be
of interest for you and then we have the
body of the chapter as one big string
here are the string counts the shortest
chapter is seven thousand characters the
longest one is over forty five thousand
and here's what they look like so
there's a you know the longer chapters
are back here and this is where a lot of
the action is actually in the novel
itself special characters need to be at
least examined if not modified they
don't did not present a problem here so
I will just skip over that so let's pull
all the chapter bodies out to work with
so some of the data claim we had to do
was convert the first three capitalized
words into a mixed case text as
appropriate I couldn't do it as a simple
rule because here's a proper noun at the
very beginning that I didn't have
anything to identify directly so it was
just easier to write very specific rules
to do that data cleaning and there were
a couple of places where there were some
new lines that weren't delimiting things
there were quite the right way there are
songs and quotations in the book
Indian chants and things like that
somebody was quoting a fellow later on
in the book and those were inside of
single curly quotes inside of double
quotes and I wanted to keep those things
together but I still wanted to be able
to preserve the the particular layout
where each knot phrase not quite a
stanza either is on its own separate
line so I kept those separated by a
single new line in paragraphs by pairs
of new lines so that's what that takes
care of there was also a problem where
there was a sentence that wasn't broken
properly and so we fixed that here and
there was also a problem where after the
the spoken parts from Othello there was
a closing curly quote but after it was
an opening double quote so somehow the
text translation got messed up but it
was very easy to fix
there was a very regular pattern so we
could fix that and get all of them taken
care of and then we took care of the new
lines in the quotations we had already
done that for the songs and the chants
and missing spaces between a couple of
words that I spotted as I was reading
through the text I probably didn't catch
all of them and and I put the processed
chapters back into the body of into the
chapter bodies notice that I didn't edit
the book text directly I did everything
l ger if Mick Lee I find that's a better
way to clean up text if you need to go
back and fix something you didn't do it
quite right the first time it's much
easier to fix a little bit of code then
go back and scan through a whole big
chunk of text and re-edit it by hand
okay
let me just quickly go through this I
structured the text breaking it up into
paragraphs so here's the first paragraph
and then those were broken up into
sentences here are the sentences from it
and then I broke those up into parts of
speech so here are the parts of speech
for each of those sentences and here's
another example here this was a chant
and that's those are the parts of speech
for it the parts of speech all of these
guys here are actually text elements and
it's a very rich data structure I won't
go into the details here and then I put
everything together into a book I won't
run this because it takes 10 to 13
minutes but a process is each chapter
and we end up then with a title the body
text that we had before
a ragged array of sentences the first
level are the paragraphs the second
level or for the individual sentences
and then for the text structure which
are the grammatical parts of speech
again a ragged array data structure one
of the first level for the paragraphs a
second level for the sentences these two
data structures are parallel so whatever
I do in this one or find in this one I
can locate in this one as well and then
I exported everything to a file so it
would be easy to pick up and use again
which I'm doing right here okay the
speech pattern in plain text is fairly
easy open curly quote the long stretch
of text without a closing curly quote
and then a closing curly quote this
works great on plain text even for
quotations that span paragraphs by the
same speaker let's say let's just jump
right through all of these here
again the number of quotes in the
different chapters here's an example of
the quote that was identified and then
here I pull out all the speech positions
in the different chapters so in the
first chapter so as this gets done there
were six pieces of quoted text in the
second paragraph the fourth paragraph
the sixth paragraph spanning into the
seventh the eleventh and the 26th and
just to pluck one out let's see yeah so
if they there were some cases where I
had them in the same paragraph but there
was there were sentences in between if
spoken text is in the same paragraph
it's the same speaker so those could be
combined and so we had 108 801 pieces of
quoted text and here's an example here
and this literate little interactive
lets me go from chapter to chapter and
and within the chapters one spoken piece
of text to the next okay what I wanted
to do next then this one and this one
here you know is that we've got some
narrative text in the middle and it
actually includes the speaker's name and
this is what we're going to be able to
use to build our network so this is my
divide and conquer strategy is to
separate out the different kinds of text
that we have those that are narrative
free and those that have narrative text
in them here's a narrative free one and
this is a function that identifies the
patterns for us and removes the the text
that's spoken so that we're left with
just the residual narrative text so
there 329
pieces of quoted text that did not have
narrative text in it
there's here's an example of what they
look like and then the ones with a
narrative text we just get by compliment
they're four hundred and seventy two of
those and here's what they look like
then we identified the speakers and this
is where we made use of the parts of
speech again we use patterns to get rid
of the quoted text so here's a sentence
with the quotes in it and then we can
remove the quoted text and we're just
left with the speaker's name and the
verb and punctuation and this is what we
worked on then and most of them were
fairly short which was good and so let's
just pull some out here here's an
example of what the text element looks
like and what we're focusing on here is
the entity that tells us what the what
the part of speech is okay this is the
list of rules that we use the list of
patterns that we use to identify the
parts of speech that we needed to
identify the speakers and then I used a
set of replacement rules after that to
actually you know take a pronoun -
followed by adverb followed by verb and
then just use the pronoun as the speaker
so we did that
and then here are the list of all the
speakers that we got there are a couple
that looked like they might be
problematic it and there and let's say
they pull them out and turns out the it
is okay because it's we're actually
referring to somebody who was in costume
so we didn't know the identity or the
author didn't want us to know the
identity right away the other two here
there is quoted text that would use to
emphasize something so that's why it was
picked up so we can get rid of these two
here again programmatically and have our
clean list of speakers this list of
rules was made by hand to take the text
elements and give us a plain string of
the character's name this I got you
because I read the book I know who the
full character's name was so this is
something that one would have to do by
hand we can get the vertices out here's
my simple rule that says that two people
had contact if they were within the same
chapter and within D paragraphs of each
other the fault being too so I construct
my edges here's the first edge I make
the network and then I can compare my
original network to the automated
network and they're not the same we
don't expect them to be the same but
there are some similarities here's Joe
Leaphorn here fairly central here he is
here fairly central as well so this is
as far as I've gotten
it's a work in progress there's a lot
more we can try pronoun resolution Co
referent resolution I can explore
dependency strings text structure does
give us what's called a pendency string
I just discovered this over the weekend
so I've got to figure out more what we
can do with it what I like about it is
it looks like we've got subject and
object out of sentences so I can use
that to help identify who's actually
speaking as opposed to being spoken
about there are more books in the series
to look at and I think machine learning
is probably going to have to be used to
make this feasible enterprise and thank
you for your attention
and being patient enough to let me run
over I'll take two questions